I am super excited to welcome you to the
press conference for Captain America
Civil War so right now I'm going to
welcome out the folks who are going to
be speaking to you today it is a
pleasure to welcome president of Marvel
Studios and producer of Captain America
Civil War Kevin Feige also Emily VanCamp
is up next come on out also mr. Don
Cheadle iron man himself that's all
about team Iron Man right now mr. Robert
Downey jr. so secondly to follow but I
know this guy can do it mr. Paul Bettany
and then last but certainly not least
the director Anthony Russo
hi everybody so Civil War am i right
you're right yes Robert this is
happening
thank you I'll enter my body any minute
now hopefully this will get you in there
now I feel like over the course of these
films we've seen like the layers of Tony
Stark peeled back to reveal like a
really emotional Center yeah do you feel
that's the case and how does that
continue in civil war um I'm still
reeling from the fact that Paul Bettany
was Jarvis and now he's vision I mean
there's something would you just stop it
he goes so here's what's going on Oh
Tony go wait a minute did he make a guy
look at him dad proud of you as far as
the emo arc of Tony over these these
bunch of years I think anyone who sticks
around for more than a minute and joins
the party here it's all about and
particularly as I'm sure either Russo
would attest it's all about that's
that's where I think Marvel has has
really done it's it's its smartest moves
you know is making sure that there's a
real emotional impact what's going on
and I am no exception
now even though civil war has this
unbelievable emotional pull I wanted to
ask you if you thought that there were
certain technological advances that
allowed for this movie to happen in the
extraordinary way that it does Wow well
look there's a man sitting next to us
that used to be Jarvis right yeah yeah
now do you mean within the world or you
mean outside in terms of filmmaking well
I mean my actual intention was for like
in the effects world like on the
technical side of the film however if
you think there's something interesting
to talk about within the world that to
oh no I can talk to look there every
movie like the the I think part of the
popularity of big special effects
derivative movies these days is the fact
that the the technology has reached just
an incredibly high level
and every movie every couple years it
changes in this movie you know you sort
of reap the benefits and you sort of
push forward on every film I mean this
movie has a very remarkable sequence I
think we're where Robert Downey jr.
plays a 20 year old man which is which
you know which is pretty incredible
he plays someone who's around the age he
was when we all first saw him on the
screen so it's like it's astounding yeah
it's a pretty various events of
nostalgia I'm told it was very elegant
it took us months and months of work on
that shot to make it work it's just it's
very complicated taking the human face
and changing the human face in a way
that looks realistic and in fact it was
the last shot we completed in the movie
just dropped into the movie maybe five
days ago on Roberts birthday look at
synchronicity abounds yeah Kevin do you
find yourself visiting set and getting
completely jealous of all of the magical
things these folks have to go through
and the heat and the conditions I don't
know if I'm jealous of the heat
necessarily but I'm also I'm in awe
always I'm in awe when they're in
costume I'm in awe when they're out of
costume and I've said it before and it's
only getting more and more so as as as
cast members keep joining there's never
been ensemble like this in in cinematic
history it's really astounding we break
it up into two panels today because it's
because everyone is a headliner and it's
and getting them in a room together as
pretty as pretty inspiring so I wanted
to know Paul you're new to the outfit do
you guys compare who's got it worse on
the set especially the new guys they're
nuts you know I think it's a photo
finish but I think that maybe I think
there may be chadwick you know with the
whole the whole not being able to
breathe businesses you can't tell the
Paul because he's British it's hard to
know exactly how excruciating we should
all be a bit more like Paul last
question
I'm stealing that could you guys talk a
little bit about bringing Spiderman into
the mix I mean it was so flawlessly done
didn't feel forced at all and it was
just like one of the amazing aspects of
the film
Peter guys talk about that sure
look it was it was very important to all
of us all the filmmakers the folks at
Marvel Kevin my brother myself the
writers
look we knew we wanted to tell a really
complicated story between Captain
America and Iron Man in this movie a
story that went to very difficult dark
places
I mean we're big fans of balance and
storytelling we like really well-rounded
movies like movies that make us laugh
and cry so for us it became very
important to find a way to change the
dynamics and modulate the tone in the
movie by bringing in characters that
didn't have the same emotional
investment that all the Avengers had in
the events that were unfolding because
they're very serious events complicated
events so to bring in characters like
Spider Man like ant-man into the movie
who don't have that baggage it gave us a
gave us an opportunity as as four
storytellers to sort of bring it bring
new colors into the film and add a deep
place in the movie lighter colors more
more more whimsical colors and I think
it just helped balance that big fight
out that they all have with one another
at the airport in a really nice way we
tried to find very organic ways that
those characters found their ways into
the movie both of those characters and
it was just you know I mean I know Kevin
can elaborate more on the decision he
was very critically central to making it
happen I don't know that a lot of people
could have pulled off getting spider-man
in this movie except for Kevin Feige so
it I think it was good answer right I
want Kevin to walk back into the
thunderous applause he deserves
[Applause]
hello my question is for dawn after
seeing the movie I feel like everybody
has new tricks and in toys and I feel
like maybe war machine hasn't gone the
upgrade that that he deserves so I
wonder if he has any animosity thank God
somebody finally made it there is Tony
has a lot of new suits since since we
first first saw her - yeah I think they
will see you know there it's not over
unless it is because I haven't seen the
movie do dis do I do I live dis washing
hubris and you'll see in the next one
wait a minute yeah I think yeah I think
there are potentially more tricks up
Warmachine sleeve we'll see you guys
have touched on it a little bit but I
think if you guys were to ask everybody
in this audience what the most exciting
sequence in this movie is they would
definitely say the airport sequence I
imagine that was one hell of a thing to
put together so I was just hoping you
could talk a bit about just kind of the
days that you were putting in production
well I just think from from my
perspective it's really interesting
because it's not until we see usually
the completed project that we know
actually what all has gone on you know
often it's these disparate you know
moments that we're trying to focus on
and you know we'll see previz and we'll
you know get the Russos will give us a
good explanation of what's happening but
it's not until you see it all together
that it's like wow yeah yeah it's really
an amazing technological feat that it
all works for the record there's an
airport sequence in this movie
question for Kevin Black Panther does
such an amazing job and this movie has a
great role to play and chadwick boseman
I think was phenomenal in his
performance so at what point did you
decide that Black Panther was going to
be an essential part of this story as
you were guys were developing the script
and then what stood out when you were
going through the process of casting
that made you know that Chadwick was the
right guy for the role of T'Challa it
was relatively early on in the in the
development process of the movie that
Joe and Anthony and our screenwriters
Chris and Steve thought it would be very
valuable to have somebody sort of in the
way that Anthony was talking about
Spidey and ant-man people that weren't
quite as invested we wanted somebody who
perhaps was invested but didn't have
allegiances to any one side who was
essentially in it for very personal
reasons himself we knew we wanted to
make a black panther movie at some point
but at that time we weren't sure exactly
when that would be but as these
discussions were going on and we thought
I think we're going to bring Black
Panther into this movie I'm not kidding
when I say Chadwick was the only choice
you know his performance at 42 his
performance and get on up how different
those performances are and my memory is
we called him on the conference room
speaker when we were developing the
movie and goddamn while he was somewhere
in Switzerland or something at a
premiere for get on up and he was in his
car either about to get out or had just
gotten back in and we said have you ever
heard of Black Panther and he went yes
yes and we said that if you want to play
the part and he was very excited and it
happened very very quickly Emily I want
to ask you really quickly like now that
this is your second film do you really
feel like you've hit a stride I mean
yeah I mean I think I was definitely
slightly intimidated in the first one in
the Winter Soldier and you know just
kind of getting used to it I think that
lent itself well for the character she
was sort of more in like a rookie stage
and and it's great to see her come back
and in a little bit more of like a
mature light she's you know confident
and and she's still good with guns girl
but yeah she's a great character to play
I'm having so much fun with her and and
you know she gets to take a little bed
in this one and you know it's great fun
I really want to know I've never heard
anybody speak to this so excuse me if
you've already spoken to it do you ever
have an idea as to where your characters
are going in the future the Marvel
Universe is so interconnected and
certainly there's a vision past what
we're seeing on the screen at the time
do you ever get clues as to play play it
to play it this way knowing that you're
going to go here eventually at some
point does that ever happen or is it a
secret from even you guys don't frown at
all sir since I would say it varies I
would say the characters don't know
what's supposed to be happening to them
so I don't know how helpful it would be
and sometimes there's a long play that I
think Paul knew for quite a while vision
was coming down the player line and had
to had to keep it a secret for quite a
while
Roberts very good at keeping secrets so
we can tell me anything at all times
locked well that one um so it really
does it really does vary there there's
some there's some big picture things I
remember pitching a sort of big twist of
Winter Soldier to Chris Evans when we
were shooting the final scenes in New
York on on the first Avengers film so
they're long things like that and then
there and then there
shorter can you come over right now
moments so this questions for mr. Russo
what about the world today demands a
popularity resurgence on superheroes
demands a popularity resurgent look you
know you can answer that question I
think in a lot of different ways but you
know we live in a very complicated world
and it seems like it gets more and more
complicated every day and I think
there's lots of signs of that that we're
all experiencing and going through and
struggling with you know there's
something very reassuring about having a
fantasy film that can deal with a lot of
these issues but in a way that's one
step removed
it's hard to deal with with reality
sometimes when it's in your face you
need you need a little buffer from it
you need it you need to place it to
within a context where your imagination
can roam and your emotions can flow in a
way that's maybe not as complicated or
threatening is in your real life so I do
think especially with these Captain
America movies because I think there's a
political dimension that's like inherent
with the character because of his origin
his name etc I don't know I think maybe
it provides us a space to play in an
explorer that's a little safer in some
ways than reality it's incredibly small
also yeah thank you sir that's an
incredible compliment coming from this
oh I just sell is being British it just
sounds small you presented in the small
just down it that's my Cleveland accent
so I called Robert relatively early
saying I think there's a chance we might
get spider-man in this movie and his
reaction was actually one just like a
fanboy which was which was unbelievably
excited for what that could mean for
this for this movie and then I would you
know a few weeks after that said hey
we've we've sort of called it down to
about five finalists could we bring them
to Atlanta and would you mind reading
with all five of them and he did and
then we called it down a little bit more
and he did in that and that was how Tom
came to the top then Tom and one other
person came back and read with did more
of a stunt test in which Chris Evans was
grace gracious enough to read opposite
him but it really it was fun seeing that
that that Robert was invested and to see
Tom react to Robert which is not
dissimilar from the way Peter was
reacting to Tony was actually quite cool
I will add this I mean obviously the
character has a very special
relationship with Roberts character in
the movie and a lot more most of his
work the vast majority of his work is
with Robert I mean it's just like Kevin
said Robert was incredibly generous in
terms of going through the process why
do you know all these reviews were going
to
I'll figure out who the right person was
for the role but not only that once Tom
got cast to all of our delight then
working with Tom a young performer and
sort of bringing him into this very
complicated fold with all these very
sophisticated performers and pedigreed
performers I mean I remember when he he
did the the big bedroom scene with Tom
and Joe and I sitting at the monitors
and just reflecting on the idea that wow
like the greatest gift that you can give
an actor is to be in the scene with
Robert Downey jr. I mean that is I
wanted to say because I didn't get to
and I've seen movie
Rodie and Tony have had this kind of
ongoing arc but then there's all this
bad guys and all the stuff that has to
happen and and what I really appreciate
is and I credit Kevin and the Rousseau's
really making sure it happens this time
is you really get back to this baseline
ongoing complicated friendship that they
have and it's obviously challenged to a
different degree and I remember when we
were doing that kind of resolution scene
and at the end and all that stuff and
that was that was before I saw miles
ahead and realized that not only did I
already thought you were great but now I
realize I'm you're probably the most
single most talented person I've ever
been working with in a long time you you
have a lot of hero versus hero fights in
this not just Downey and Evans but I
mean a lot and I was just wondering if
you could talk a little bit about the
process of pairing up those conflicts
and more importantly how you integrated
them with the story and turn it into
mourning than just you know random
slugfests it's a it's a complicated
question you know look we thought about
we look at my brother and I always say
that we love action where actions
fetishists but you know it's like for us
action always needs to be driven by a
sense of character and a sense of story
beat by beat by beat through through the
action sequence or else you just lose
interest in it it has no value to the
storytelling so we look for
opportunities in the movie
play with these rich complicated
relationships there's a very interesting
relationship between Paul's character in
this movie and lose the Olsens character
the movie Scarlet Witch envisioned you
know that that begins to develop an
interesting complicated relationship and
to put them out in opposite sides you
know in the in the battle was it was
very exciting to us because it sort of
interfered with what was happening the
dynamic between these character and
watching these characters and watching
him push that forward I mean what did
that just to ask you Pollak how did that
how did that sort of like inform your
your experience of it having having a
personal relationship with a character
while at the same time finding yourself
on the opposite side in a fight I think
it's a really really interesting idea
you find vision at this you know in age
of Ultron he is just born and omnipotent
yet naive and then in this movie you
find him trying to figure out what
Humanity is and and and and and and how
you have loyalty because logic doesn't
afford loyalty so I think he's really
interested in working out what love is
you know and and there's this woman who
has a similar problem that he's facing
which is he doesn't know the limits of
his power and nor does she and and you
know of course you know love can make
you feel loyal and at the end of this
movie I think you know it's a
double-edged sword because you see this
his his response finally having a human
response is he makes a big he makes a
big mistake which is which is
interesting and I thought it was a
really deft piece of storytelling so it
was yeah it was really fun to do moving
especially moving forward
I know your background with revenge and
you were always kicking butt on there
and with this character you just
mentioned that you did have a little bit
of a chance to kind of kick ass but do
you ever want to do more since that is
something that you're very familiar with
and you did on revenge and yeah I love
it I love all the physical stuff you
know and it's brilliantly done in these
movies but I also think it you know it's
great about these films as you're also
you know developing these characters
over time and so that's one element you
know that's great but I also really
enjoyed getting to really share sharin
with the audience as well because we we
only knew her as agent 13 and and sort
of explore that relationship with Steve
that was that was really interesting to
me because their relationship in the
comic books was great and complicated
and interesting and you know we're sort
of just delving into that now which was
really fun so I loved all of that stuff
you know all of it together is is great
I actually have a two-part question
first for Kevin and Anthony when you
make a movie like this and you have so
many characters what's the biggest
struggle with putting each character in
there for screen time and knowing the
right amount and then for the actors
what do you think about each of your
characters is the characteristic that
draws audiences into their those roles
okay well I think I think so much of the
credit for your first question are the
success with with balancing those
characters goes to Chris Marcus and
Steve McFeely who really know that you
talked about about Spidey
screen time doesn't equal you know it's
it's it's quality not quantity right if
people have moments that land if people
have never have a laugh if people have a
cheer that's sometimes all you need to
say this character has been serviced
let's let's let's move on to the bigger
story and and Joan Anthony are always so
adamant rightfully so that the overall
story is being serviced as opposed to
every single character in the film so
you I think that's
how you take this many characters and
balance a singular relatively simple
story and have them there in each of
their moments where they earn a laugh or
earn a tear or on a cheer serve the very
specific story at hand well I watch the
movie with a stopwatch to see what is it
that you think draws people to your
characters guys like do you is do you
think there's a central characteristic
well that I know that roadies always
trying to and in this movie too he's
always struggling with what does he owe
as a servicemen and what is his duty and
chain of command and how must that be
protected and honored but also I'm in
this team of people who some of them are
you know have have as Paul was saying no
limit to to their power and where are
the checks and balances and that's
something that's obviously central to
this this film as well but I think
that's a understandable sort of fence
that that he's on and how do you
friendship versus you know chain of
command and all the things that I think
roadies trying to to balance as he goes
forward with this group guys do any of
you have anything to add to that I think
it's a really interesting question as we
wind up like what why why do people just
love you yeah I just think the vision
that the synthetic people around the
world could get and yearning to break
free from the shackles of expectation
that you know they really get behind my
character I think I speak for them your
tvq in the mannequin world is onion
honestly they're right
questions we're talking with spider-man
a second ago my question is uh how
exactly did Tony know about spider-man
and does how he no mean that he is aware
of like the other New York heroes wait
never mind as we were picking up Peter
Parker's story at a point out after
which he's gotten his powers but before
which he's fully sort of coming out so
he had you know in our storytelling he
has been doing some things in New York
and there's been sent these sort of
sasquatch-like videos of what he's been
doing that's been showing up you've
heard word-of-mouth that something's
happening there's this very strange
thing happening so it's kind of
something that's in the rumor mill but
nobody has been able to identify who
exactly this is yet or how it's
happening etc but of course Tony Stark
being who Tony Stark is he's one step
ahead of everybody else
you